Support for Donald Trump's impeachment has
exploded drastically since the start of the
impeachment inquiry against Donald Trump was
announced last week.
Half of those who have an opinion about this
say that the impeachment process should start.
It's 43 to 43 with about 13% undecided.
This 43% number is up nearly 20% from the
last poll, which had only 36% supporting impeachment.
That is now up to 43% that is a 20% increase.
Don't email me and say I'm wrong.
I'm not saying it's a 20 percentage point
increase.
It's a 20% increase.
Very importantly, support for impeachment
is up, not just among Democrats.
Also among some Republicans and even some
independent support for the impeachment inquiry
has increased and let's dig into it a little
more to get a better understanding.
Uh, there's an argument.
The argument is support for impeachment will
go up as more information from the impeachment
inquiry comes out and people realize what
it is Donald Trump is accused of doing.
The poll has data that supports that assertion.
Shockingly, in this poll, only 34% of Americans
say that they heard some about the Ukraine
fiasco.
Another 34% in this poll say they haven't
heard much or anything about the Ukraine fiasco,
so understand that with 68% of respondents
saying they've either heard nothing, not much
or only some about the Ukraine fiasco, 43%
still support impeachment.
This supports the idea that as people learn
about what has taken place support for impeachment
will go up even more.
This poll, by the way, was taken before we
heard from acting director of national intelligence,
Joe Maguire in congressional testimony.
This was a poll taken before the release of
the recording in which Donald Trump implies
that the whistle blower or the informant to
the whistleblower should be killed.
This 43% support level was before.
Lots of the things that we've since learned,
and then we have a newer CBS news poll where
55% of Americans approve with the impeachment
inquiry an even higher number, meaning 55
minus 36 is 1919 divided by 36 that's more
than a 50% increase, not percentage point,
more than a 50% increase from one before all
of this from before all of this started.
Now that all being said, this impeachment
inquiry could still backfire on Democrats.
The reference point is look at how bill Clinton's
impeachment backfired on Republicans in the
1990s that's a fair point of contrast.
Although there were some important differences
with the bill Clinton situation.
Clinton generally was more likable than Trump,
but that's not my opinion.
That's the polling bill Clinton didn't interfere
in the impeachment process while Trump already
is and certainly will continue to do so.
Clinton's impeachment.
In the end, he lied, but he lied, uh, related
to an affair that he had.
Trump has been caught red handed suppressing
whistleblower reports about his bribery and
extortion of Ukraine for the benefit of his
2020 reelection campaign.
So there are important differences between
the Clinton impeachment and the Trump and
peach mint.
With Trump, we are only at step one, which
is the inquiry that's up, that's all.
That's where we are right now.
But support up drastically since stress, before
this was announced, let me know what you think
about all of this.
Let me know what you think about the inquiry.
Let me know what you think about support for
the inquiry.
I'm on Twitter at Deepak Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
I will be streaming tonight probably on twitch@twitch.tv
slash [inaudible]
David Pacman, and I hope you'll join me
there as well.